what do you think most people
misunderstand about stress yeah the
findings that I think are overlooked
tremendously are the following
experiment um there's an experiment in
animals where a rat is given the
opportunity to run on a treadmill and
rats and and rodents of all kind love
kinds love running on treadmills you
know they're these interesting um we'll
see who catches this fly first yeah I'm
ready man the uh I think um you know
there's even a study from hoppy hofer's
Lab at at Harvard that showed that if
you put a wheel
running Wheels in fields that rodents
will run there in the middle of the
night and run on them that's how
insanely uh obsessed with running
they're just energetic they want to go
there's something rewarding about it for
them but in any event it lowers their
blood pressure it leads to Inc
improvements in a number of metrics that
you expect and you see the same thing in
humans right who run on a treadmill or
run Outdoors or Swim cardiovascular
exercise okay well um spolski um and I
love to talk about a an experiment where
they took two different cages with
animals one is running voluntarily but
then that running wheel is Tethered to a
running wheel in another cage that
encloses an animal forces it to run
every time the other one runs so forced
exercise versus voluntary exercise and
the takeaway is very straightforward
voluntary exercise leads to all sorts of
improvements in health metrics resting
heart rate blood pressure blood glucose
um resting blood glucose Etc waking
blood glucose um the animal that's
forced to exercise you see the opposite
right so it's not exercise per se it's
something about being forced to exercise
is causes um decrements in a number of
Health metrics and you see the same
thing in humans so what's Wild is my
colleague Dr Ali Crum Department of
psychology at Stanford um has done these
beautiful experiments on mindset and
belief these are not Placebo effects and
what she's shown in in a just absolutely
spectacular way is that if people watch
a short video about all the ways in
which stress can really diminish your
health well then indeed stress
diminishes their health whereas if a
separate group watches an a factual also
five minute also factual tutorial on all
the ways that stress can enhance
performance by harnessing your ability
to focus memory formation Etc all which
is true that's indeed what you see can I
give you my favorite one that I learned
about over the last year yes so the
Boston Marathon
bombing uh
2012 about 10 years ago 2016 maybe
anyway Boston Marathon bombing
a study was done comparing people who
had been at the actual Marathon while
the bomb had gone off and people who had
watched 90 minutes or more of news
coverage about it and the people who
coverage about it showed a greater
stress response than the people who'
literally lived through it interesting
interesting yeah
the the um the the mindset and belief
effects are are absolutely extraordinary
and and and very real right I mean I
think you know um recently I've been
reading and researching a lot about and
did a podcast on tenacity and willpower
and um there was this idea early on from
balme and colleagues that willpower is a
limited resource some of ego depletion
will depletion um it was controversial
um they showed that you know
replenishing glucose in between hard
tasks could restore willpower they
showed that uh was it juries or judges
that were low in blood glucose were more
likely to give harsher sentences stuff
like this yeah it it sort of wicked out
to a number of naturalistic situations
and it made good sense and then my
colleague Carol DW also in the
psychology department at Stanford um
most famously known for her work on mind
growth mindset did an experiment in
which they um essentially asked whether
or not tenacity and willpower are
limited in terms of being a some sort of
resource and also whether or not it was
somehow linked to glucose availability
fuel uh in the brain and body and found
that if people thought or were told that
mind that uh excuse me willpower was a
limited resource that's indeed what they
observed experimentally but that if they
were taught or were told that willpower
is unlimited and and divorced from
glucose levels well then that's exactly
what you saw you're saying that learning
about ego depletion and believing that
willpower is a limited resource is an
information Hazard that is
self-fulfilling uh potentially now now
now now bow Meister you know showed um
himself to be you know pretty determined
um when and countered the the uh the DW
counter by showing that if indeed if
there's a hard task followed by a hard
task then your beliefs about willpower
um Can impact your performance on the
second task so D the AKA D is right but
that if you have a hard task hard task
and then another hard task so back to
back to back tasks or more which is a
lot of what life is like well then it
seems that the W that the willpower is a
limited resource and glucose supporting
will willpower Theory holds up a bit
better what have you come to believe
about the difference between willpower
and motivation and discipline how how do
kind of all of these fit together in
your mind yeah so willpower and tenacity
um are related to motivation but they're
not quite the same I think we should
think of motivation as a um as the verb
state that moves us from um let's just
say apathy to tenacity okay so it's it's
it's the verb function that moves us
along that Continuum a apathy at one end
tenacity and willpower but strong um
exertion of willpower at the other end
um one of the most interesting
structures in the entire nervous system
is one that gets very little coverage
unfortunately um in fact most
neuroscientists aren't aware of what its
function is and it's called the amcc
which is the anterior mid singulate
cortex you have one on each side of the
brain the name isn't really important
but we want to you know to to the credit
of the of the structure we should name
it the
amcc the amcc receives inputs from a lot
of interesting brain areas related to
reward related to autonomic function so
how alert or sleepy we are to prediction
to prediction error it's a hub for many
many inputs and outputs hormone systems
Etc beautiful experiments done by my
colleague Joe pery at Stanford have
shown that if you stimulate this brain
area tiny little brain area in a human
they immediately feel as if some
challenge is impending and they're going
to meet that challenge it's a forward
Center of mass against challenge
response this has been seen in
independent subjects they do controls
where they then tell them they're
stimulating but they're not actually
stimulating and they're like I don't
feel anything you can turn on and off
tenacity and willpower so there's
literally a hub for this now here's
where it gets really interesting I'm
going to list off a bunch of
peer-reviewed published results in Rapid
sequence and I'm happy to uh point out
the the um substantiation for this or
the references okay individuals that are
dieting or resisting some sort of
tempting behavior and are successful in
doing that the size and activity in
their amcc goes up over time and the
structure gets bigger dieters who
fail flat or downward trajectory of the
size and activation of the
amcc this can be taken too far
individuals with anorexia nervosa the
most deadly of all psychiatric disorders
where a dep self-deprivation of food
activates excessive reward there's this
kind of loop of reward their AMC's are
significantly greater size than others
so there's you know this can be taken
too
far
superagers which is a bit of a misnomer
because these individuals are people who
maintain healthy cognitive function
similar to people in their 20s and 30s
into their 70s 80s and 90s their amcc
maintains or increases in size into
their later years typical agers the size
of we always hear that you lose brain
mass across your lifespan well most of
it is from the amcc and beautifully and
this is two of my favorite results that
really bring this around to a protocol
or a takeway if people are given an easy
task the amcc isn't activated if they're
given a hard task in particular a hard
task physical or cognitive that they
really don't want to do the amcc levels
of activity go through the roof and
here's what's really cool they gave
aging let's you know people age 60 to 79
the task of adding three hours extra per
week of cardiovascular exercise now
that's a lot right three one hour they
call them aerobic classes but getting
their heart rate up to about 65 70% of
of Maximum so it's getting into like
Zone 3ish area yeah people can look up
zone three but you nailed it zone three
the size of their amcc increased across
that six-month protocol and offset the
normal age related decline in this in
this sprain area in terms of its
size the theory that's starting to
emerge is that the amcc isn't just about
tenacity and willpower to push through
hard things that it may actually be
related to one's will to live one's will
to continue living and I think this is
these are some of the most important
results by the way I didn't participate
in any of the research that I just
described I spent a lot of time with
that literature but I think it's so
important I mean we hear about the
amydala the hippocampus the prefrontal
cordex all of very important brain
structures but um if nothing else
hopefully this conversation put the amcc
on the map the one that literally could
create your will to live is the one
that's being overlooked a little bit and
and it can be and what's interesting
about this structure is that it's
involved in generating tenacity and
willpower for all things not just for
one situation and what's really
wonderful I think about the the research
literature on this is It's So Clear what
we need to do we need to do th let's say
like me you you're a person who enjoys
weightlifting and you love running I
love those two activities well guess
what those activities even if they're
hard like a hard run that I'm really
enjoying or some hard sets in the gym
not going to increase the size or
activity of the amcc people love to over
romanticize the utility of those final
two reps sure okay pushing to failure
great you know running hard till your
lungs burn great but if you enjoy that
you're not increasing your amount of
tenacity and willpower at least
according to the research data what's
going to do it is doing something what I
call Micro sucks or macro sucks you know
and so micros sucks could be all the
little things that you don't want during
to do during the day macro suck could be
the larger things but of course you
don't want to do things that are going
to damage you psychologically or
physically of course of course but
everyone I believe would benefit from um
picking a few micro sucks what are some
of your micro sucks or macro sucks that
you could sprinkle throughout the day
okay so on a household maintenance level
um you know I I maintain a very clean
home I I I'm constantly throwing things
away as well but there are a few things
like once I exceed a certain number of
dishes in the sink it becomes this okay
I'll I'll load the dishwasher later type
thing like a micro suck for me would be
like especially if something's been in
there for a while and it's kind of gross
and you got to like work through it and
of course I try and put each dish away
as as I you know dirty them up but um so
little things the things like that the I
really don't want to deal with that
right now that's the kind of thing those
harder tasks where you have to breach
some barrier some resistance to put it
into you know step pressfield language
or um our friend David gogins right you
know this idea that one has to callous
the mind I mean it David said that right
he's probably got an hypertrophied amcc
that's bigger than most people's
probably and and the the beauty of
having a a an amcc that's highly you
know available for Activation is that
you know through the micro and the macro
sucks of the day you you have this thing
it's like an engine that you can devote
to other things so then you can devote
the amcc to other endeavors I have this
thing I called email anxiety and it's
when my unread inbox reaches three
figures or more and that's when it just
it kind of follows me around like a
poltergeist throughout the day and that
that absolutely that's probably a macro
suck you know to get through that it's
probably three to four hours a lot of it
scheduling when's this guest coming on I
need to speak to this partner we go blah
blah blah um so yeah I feel that um what
else subjective right I mean what's a
what sucks is sub someone else might
love email yeah someone might and and I
think that um you know you've talked a
lot on your show with various guests
about you know when we're in too much
comfort uh are we're not meeting our
goals I love deadlines for that reason
um I I love deadlines I love pressure I
I think Parkinson's law is as close to a
thermodynamic of productivity as we can
get do you know what I mean
like when you have a deadline you will
meet it right if you do not have a
deadline you will Manana Manana until
forever that's right and some people I
think um preload the deadline by
procrastinating and then that's what you
know gets their activation energy to a
level where they can they can can engage
so I've started thinking about this a
lot lately you know I love running but
it's interesting I I like to finish it
my driveway and I live on a hill and um
actually this morning I was out for a
run and the gate at the end of the Colac
is my sort of designated stop point so
it actually sucked to do the last you
know 20 meters um this morning so there
I probably got a little bit of amcc
activation because everything was the
number of negotiations I went through
when I turned up my street at the end of
this run whether or not I was going to
run this extra 20 M was ridiculous I
mean the human brain you know struggling
to not do this extra 20 MERS it was so
silly so it's got to it's got to hurt a
little bit again you don't want to
damage yourself but I think in the
context of um for instance cognitive
learning getting to the point where you
finish something and then forcing
yourself to do one little extra bit
there at the end so you know I I I'm not
looking for any credit for it but I want
to be very clear that the scientific
literature doesn't call these things
micros sucks I call them micros sucks um
and I S put that out there just to make
it um clear as to what we're referring
to you know Nick bear I don't in Austin
he's a athlete andle supplement yeah
yeah yeah yeah like a hybrid athlete a
larger guy but he runs really fast does
bodybuilding shows does powerlifting
also runs to be clear I know that large
guys run fast but um typically they
don't run uh fast for 20 miles correct
and he does that's accurate um he his
little uh catchphrase is go one more and
it's interesting what you're saying here
is it's not just about the completion of
the thing that you're doing because a
lot of the time the thing that you
choose to do even the thing that's
difficult is done under your own valtion
don't get me wrong if you do a difficult
crossfit workout Fran whatever 2159 of
thrusters and
pull-ups it is aw it's hell right
there's literally a name for what your
throat feels like once you finished
called Fran cof that people get from
having taken their heart rate as high as
spasming um that taste of metal in the
back of your throat but what what people
are doing there although they're doing
something that's difficult it's like
ially difficult and it's within their
domain of enjoyment and what you're
saying here is that we're we're looking
to just push ourselves a little bit past
that it's like an unnecessary amount of
Challenge and I think that go one more
makes quite a nice uh reminder for us
with the micro sucker the macro sucker
let's push ourselves just a little bit
beyond where we would have got our sense
of satisfaction because presumably you
get the dopamine I've completed the task
[__] yeah and then it's like and then I
do just that tiny little bit more to to
bring we'll get back to talking to in
one minute but first I need to tell you
about mudwater mudw water is a coffee
alternative that tastes like chai and
cacao had a baby it's got four
functional mushrooms and with only a
fraction the caffeine as a cup of coffee
you will get all of the natural energy
without the Jitters or crash each
ingredient was added for a purpose cacao
and chai for a hint of coffee and hot
chocolate likee flavor Lion's man for
Focus ceps to promote Natural Energy and
both cha and Reet to support a healthy
immune system plus it's Whole 30
approved 100% USDA or organic certified
non-GMO gluten-free vegan and kosher so
if you are looking for a delicious
alternative to your morning coffee this
is a great place to start right now you
can get $20 off your first order plus a
whole box of good stuff including
creamer and a free fror by going to the
link in the description below or heading
to mudw tr.com
slod wisdom that's mudw tr.com
slod wisdom thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that clip with
Dr hubber and you will love the 3our
episode that you can watch right here go
on press it